még az jutott eszembe akár az idős akár
a gyerekek korosztályát tekintve vagy
egyáltalán hogy ez a két
célcsoportot nézzük hogy hogy ugye a
figyelem megint nagyon-nagyon fontos
hogy mennyi figyelmet és időt tudunk
fordítani úgy a gyerekekre mint a az
idősebb korosztályra hogy mennyi időt
töltünk velük és hogy mennyi időt
töltünk azzal hogy ezt a digitális témát
egy kicsit beépítsük hogyha aktuális ez
ugyanúgy érvényes szerintem a
nagyszülőkre is hogy velük is
elbeszélgetni ezekről a dolgokról érezni
hogy tőlünk kapnak figyelmet nem
feltétlen kell a a fülöpszigeteki
szerelmüktől várják azt az odafigyelést
tehát hogy sokszor amúgy itt rejtőzik a
a nyuszi hogy hogy hogy valamilyen
hiányt pótolunk a közösségi médiával és
és hogy ezekre a hiányokra érdemes
nagyobb hangsúlyt fektetni